okay let's get more on the government's
response ongoing response to the corona
virus pandemic and we can talk to the
Secretary of State for help Matt Hancock
good to see you this morning look we are
according to the experts and it seems
pretty clear from looking at the figures
where we are now at almost 9,000 that we
are hurtling towards hitting 10,000
coronavirus linked deaths this weekend
that's a really a horrific figure well
it look my job as health secretary is to
is to protect life and this underlines
how important it is for everybody to
follow the social distancing rules and
to stay at home just as your reporter
was saying that and it you know if if
anybody thinks that it's okay to slacken
up when it's clear that although the you
know there are signs of the curve
flattening which is good news and we
shouldn't throw away that that good work
of flattening the curve but it's still
clear that the that the virus is
spreading in the community and we've got
to make sure that we stop that and so
people really do need to stay at home
this this Easter weekend look I know it
has been made very clear throughout all
the briefings that the government has
been following scientific advice that's
understandable you've got to rely on the
experts but nevertheless do we think now
with a little bit of hindsight that that
advice was not necessarily right that we
didn't take enough stringent action
early on
no we as you say we followed the advice
and we also looked abroad of what was
happening and we made those decisions I
think the right decisions to bring in
this this lockdown and at the right time
of what matters and what I concentrate
on every single day and what we spend
our time working on is what is the best
route now and what should we be doing
next and the very clear
evidence from the from what's happening
from if you look at the number of cases
and the number of people going into
hospital and what is clear is that the
measures are working but we're not there
yet and so people should take heart that
the measures are working because it is
bringing this this epidemic under
control but also be resolute in that we
have we're not there yet and so we need
this this to continue and of course
we'll keep reviewing that advice and the
scientists the scientific advisory group
are meeting next week but for this
weekend the message is really crystal
clear which is to stay at home and in
terms of that messaging and you say it's
crystal clear I've got to say from a
personal perspective I've not found it
difficult to understand but there are
people who've said to me that the
government has not been specific enough
and particularly when we're looking at
last weekend and no doubt we will see
some of it this weekend sadly of people
not really following the rules do you
have to be even more precise and say if
you go out this weekend you go out for
an hour tops
you must keep moving you cannot sit down
you cannot have a barbecue you can't sit
down with a flask of tea whatever it is
do you have to be absolutely crystal
clear and all that advice well I think
we have been we I was asked last weekend
whether it was okay to to stop and have
a picnic and the answers that it is is
truly no because the reason that you can
go out for exercise is to get exercise
and because of the very positive
benefits that you get from exercise so
we have been crystal clear as as you say
the vast vast majority of people are
following the rules and Memorial II
pleased over the last week or so to see
that the number of people following the
rules which we track and the proportion
and there hasn't been as slackening off
people are continuing to follow the very
stringent rules despite the impact
it has and we understand that I
understand it and and so actually the
the amount of adherence to the social
distancing rules is something that I'm
very pleased about of course I always
want to see you know everybody following
and there is a very small minority who
flout it but actually if you look at the
figures and if you look at the data that
we use to try to measure these things
there is a very very high degree of
support for the measures and adherence
to the measure and so I you know I want
to thank people who do follow the
measures and then of course along with
the police we we try to get that
proportion increasing all the time there
is some very confusing messaging not
from the government but from all these
sort of academics and things in all this
when we've been talking about a vaccine
because we heard only a week or so ago
people with some experts are saying a
vaccine was going to be middle of next
year in The Times today there's this
article coming from from a very
high-ranking scientists in Oxford's
talking about the possibility absolutely
pushing us to the limits but we might be
able to get something into production by
September clearly you're across all the
research door the work that's going on
here what what do you understand a
realistic timetable to be like I am I am
engaged in in all of that and I know of
the I know quite a lot about the Oxford
project and it is really great to see
some hope on the especially on the front
page of the newspapers and but the way
that I think about it is as follows and
we will put all the resources we
possibly can into getting a vaccine
because of the massive benefits that
we'd have to have our vaccine and we're
also putting enormous resources into
making sure that when a vaccine comes
about if and when then we can
manufacture enough here to be able to
get it to everybody as quickly as
possible because it's not just about
discovering the vaccine and then
checking that it's safe
but it's also then about manufacturing
it and we have got vaccine manufacturing
capability in this country but it needs
expanding so we're doing that in
parallel once we wait for the scientists
to develop a vaccine that we're happy
with and then essentially to make sure
that whatever the outcome of the science
however fast that happens and we are
ready ready to get the regulatory
approvals ready to get the production
and ready to get it logistically to
everybody who needs it so in a sense my
job is not to have a particularly to
have a view on how fast that will happen
and I think the truth is it's impossible
to know but it's but it's nice to see
some some hope as I say my job is to
make sure that as and when the
scientists make their breakthroughs and
you know there's no way I could do the
science I leave that to them and the
country is ready to step up pick up the
science turn it into mass production and
get it out and and that there aren't any
barriers in the way whether financial or
regulatory or in terms of capabilities
to the scientists making the fastest
progress that they possibly can but
there are some barriers in place I mean
there's been talk a lot of talk about
this plasma therapy in order to combat
covert 19 the government had not
approved trials for plasma therapy why
is that well if an individual clinician
recommends it then that can be used and
we are expanding the trials of different
of different medicines different
therapies all of the time in fact we
have one of the biggest trials program
in the whole world going on in this
country for instance you might heard of
hydroxychloroquine which is much
discussed and we have one of the biggest
trials of hydroxychloroquine
in the world and and in the same way
that we follow the scientific advice on
social distancing so - we're determined
to follow the scientific advice and
follow the science on making sure we get
these treatments in get them in in a
within a clinical trials
we collect the data we really understand
what works and what doesn't work what
sort of dosage apply to which patients
at what time so that we can then learn
from them and treat more people more
effectively so you know the one that you
mentioned is a is something that I've
seen and I know is available to the
right people on the NHS where that's
where that's clinically appropriate
those decisions for any individual
patient of course have got to be made by
the clinician who's treating look I want
to talk to you about PPE in just a
second before we get to that though can
we can we talk about the number of
people on the front line who have caught
and sadly passed away from kovat 19 what
sort of figures are we looking at at the
moment well at the moment 19 people have
died from the NHS family the yeah the
true for those for them it is a and it's
a heartbreaking heartbreaking story and
I know that it affects everybody who
works in the NHS to see their their
colleagues died and I think that the the
important thing is to work out to what
extent people contracted it in the line
of duty so to speak because of course
you know people can have caught it from
all sorts of different reasons and you
mentioned pee pee wee wee wee aren't
aware of any link from shortages of PPE
to any of these these deaths but my
heart goes out to their families and and
I I've said already that I think the
fact that such a high proportion also
are from people who move to this country
to work for the NHS is a it's really
heart rending to see people who've given
they're literally given their lives for
the NHS who moved here and to give that
service and and and I think we should
pay tribute to them
what absolutely I think everyone would
agree with you on that but in terms of
of the PPE there was now I heard you in
the news conference last night I have to
say it did strike me a little bit and it
no doubt it's a valid point to say look
the PPE s here there's a logistic issue
you're getting it around the the 58,000
bases whatever you mentioned they but
there was the has been certainly
reported on Twitter and elsewhere a
sense of anger in that you did say
however legitimate it may be about
saying you only wear the PPE when you
need to only use the pieces that you
need to when you're on the frontline
when you're actually dealing with this
perhaps you are getting through more PPE
then may be absolutely necessary but we
can't criticize people for doing that
can we no and there's I won't criticize
people for doing that but I will
reiterate how important it is to use
exactly the right amount of PPE as you
say that it's an important point to make
because PPE is a precious resource and
we need to make sure that it's used
appropriately and that everybody has it
you know that every single person gets
it which is why it's such a complicated
logistical exercise getting millions of
pieces of PPE to the right to the right
person and to the millions of people who
work across health and social care can I
mention something to you that we I spoke
earlier on a couple of hours ago to dr.
Julian Tang who is an expert in in these
respiratory conditions and and how they
are spread and he said although PPE is
very important it was at the bottom of
his sort of inverted triangle of the
measures that you need to do to stop
these sort of issues particularly within
hospitals and care homes he said that
actually ventilation was much more
important you know even at using
ventilation systems better but also you
know literally opening windows can
actually have a real impact on how this
virus is being spread well
think there's a lot of wisdom in that
and the of course you know the top pro
the absolute top priority is making sure
that NHS capacity always above the the
demand for it I mean you know one of the
one of the things that we've managed to
achieve during this crisis is always
ensuring that there's enough capacity in
the NHS to treat everybody and give
everybody the top class treatment that
they need and so that's the absolute
number one ventilators is clearly a part
of that and getting testing right is
incredibly important
keeping there's a whole program of work
all the way through all and and we just
got it we work night and day on getting
on doing the very best we can on wor
them can I come on finish off I want to
ask you about the the the lockdown I
mean it's been well reported and some
experts have come forward and said look
it looks like the lockdown will have to
be extended we haven't had that definite
word yet
don't don't we need that as soon as
possible we need to be told rather than
having this this waiting period of three
or four days we need to be told now
don't we that this is going to be
extended through to the beginning of May
the only one thing that matters when it
comes to people making decisions about
how they get what they're going to do
this Easter weekend there's only one
thing that matters for that or all the
other discussion is important and I'm
quite happy to answer questions about it
there's only one thing that matters in
terms of what people do this weekend and
every single person can play their part
in the national effort to defeat this
virus by staying at home that's what I'm
doing and that's what everybody should
do Secretary of State good2talk team
thank you thank you